I've been working on for a year from
proposal to it being done and it does
feel like I gave her a very long painful
tiring but wonderful verse Lily sings
book how to be about is a collection of
fifty life lessons that the 28 year old
has learned from famous friends and life
experiences since becoming a social
media superstar it's time to learn how
to do about the book is different in the
sense that I'm vulnerable in it and I'm
talking about lessons and I tell the
things I've learned not every page on
the book it will take you laughs Wayne
Wow Jesus what are you doing here my
hormones Wayne is a great example of
someone who is a huge role model to me
and it's the biggest thing about Duane
that inspires me is that he's constantly
breaking the mold and now he has so many
ventures I should just talk to him this
morning because his new shoe was sold
out worldwide and I was like now you're
selling out shoes like come on leave
something for the rest of us then he
said do not let people tell you what you
should do create your path break the
mold and bust tradition was an exact
term it's about seeing a system in place
being like this is cool but also I'm
going to make my own oh me okay and Lily
had done just that using her superwoman
brand to help empower young women around
the world
earlier in hospital I creates up a hill
gorilla and it's my social good campaign
to and the cycle of girl-on-girl hate
and encourage women to support other
women because I'm a big believer that
true women build other women up and so
the bra tops challenge is all about
throwing support literally two other
women by throwing your bra to the camera
tag you're it
little did Lily know her challenge would
be accepted by fellow activist Charlize
Theron oh I wasn't even close how this
is a phenomenal human being I love her
to death all the way it's nice to have
support from people that are so busy
have such a big name but really care
about issues that are still dear to my
heart and I know her the love